Herkese
merhaba ben Esra Banu Sipahi
mı sorumuz on yedi harften oluşan bir
kavram yukarıdan aşağıya numaralı soruyu
soruyorum
çevresel sorunların tanımlanmasında ve
sınırların çizilmesinde etkili olan
toplum içindeki bormer ve enformel
kurumların ve aktörlerin arasındaki
etkileşim nedir acaba
Aslında bu kavram sorunların aşılmasında
cevresel krizin aşılmasında birçok
organizasyonu topluluğu politika ve
karar alma araçlarını destekleyici
finansal mekanizmaları düzenlemeleri
hukuk kurallarının devlet ve hükümet
dışı kuruluşları ve bunlara ilişkin
kuralları kapsar bu
kavram sürdürülebilir kalkınma için
etkin bir çevre üretimini görmektedir ve
bu kavramın bazı belirleyicileri
bulunmaktadır mesela yapılar var
aktörlerden bahsediyoruz Yapı
dediğimizde sivil toplum kuruluşları çok
uluslu şirketler devletler yerel
yönetimler vatandaşlar gibi
ikinci bileşeni kavramın normal mesela
kanunlar sosyal normal hakim güç
ilişkileri de buna dahil edilebilir
kavramın diğer belirleyicisi ise
süreçler pırasalı Yetkilerin dile
getirilmesi değerlerin müzakere edilmesi
yasak
oluşturulmaz politika belirleme ve
bilginin yayılması ve politikaların
uygulanması gibii Evet bu sorumuzun
cevabı çevresel ve iletişim kavramı
ressam iletişim bazı eleştirileri konu
olmakla birlikte bu çevre yıkımından
hepimizin mesul olması nedeniyle
şirketleri
Devletleri insanları sivil toplumu dahil
etmesi nedeniyle Aslında küresel krizin
aşılması noktasında önemli bir anahtar
kavram diyebiliriz
o olacak ulusal ve
uluslararası çalışan sorunları
burada çalışan prensip normal
[Müzik]
prensesler benim telefon ücretli olarak
çalışan
[Müzik]
kurallar çalışan önemli
değil mi
çok güzel olalım ki bunları Bilmeden Çok
oluşturur Bu sadece Bizler Pınarbaşı'nda
iklim değişikliği ve değiştir o zaman
yanındadır iklim değişikliği konusunda
görsel
[Müzik]
olmasını
bizimde
[Müzik]
Arkadaşlar merhaba
Biz ondan sonra 12 oluyor insan ve çevre
cisminin çevirdik yeniden tanımlanmasını
siyasi düşüncelerle baktığınızda siyah
siyah sana yakın bu gibi tamam olacak
nasıl bir saate sorusunu sormak
gerekiyor Bunun cevabını bugün Nisan
geçebilirsin çevrenin doğal
sanıyorum cevabınız bir
bulmacada bu konuyu
siyasete
dünyanın tasavvuruna sahip ilk
davranış ve
düşünce
tartışma
aslında bir parçası beş
farklı siyasi
bilmesi çıkış noktamız Eğer
bu doğanın hakimi değildi açısıdır
olursak Bence daha yaşanabilir bir dünya
Doğru yol alabiliriz diye düşündüm
bu
dördüncü kelimemiz yukarıdan aşağıya
bireylerin grupların veya toplumların
yöresel bozulmalara karşı duyarlı
olmalarını ve olumsuz etkileri
önlemlerini amaçlayan güvenlik alanıdır
yukarıdan aşağı 4 çevresel güvenlik
çevre ve güvenlik ilişkisi çok eskilere
dayanmasına karşın çevresel güvenlik
kavramı 20 yüzyılın sonlarına doğru
soğuk savaşın bitişiyle
kendine yer bulabilir güvenlik
çalışmaları içerisinde
Milas'ta iki kutuplu dünyanın çökmesiyle
birlikte
güvenlik devlet Merkezi güvenlik
anlayışında insan Merkezi güvenlik
anlayışına doğru evlenmiş ve Bu bağlamda
insan güvenliği kapsamında
değerlendirilen çevresel güvenlik
hem yerel hem küresel biyosferin
ekolojik dengenin kurulmasıyla da
alakalıdır bu noktada çevresel güvenlik
farklı grupların çevresel tehditlerden
çevresel tahribattan
etkilenmesi olarak kavramsallaştırma
bilir
o Merhaba arkadaşlar bugün bulmacada
bana denk gelen kavram 5 numara da on
dört harften oluşuyor şöyle bir kavram
çevresel bozulmalar ve faydaların
farklısınız etnik grup ve cinsiyete
sahip insanlar arasında eşitsiz biçimde
dağılması dır eşitsiz biçimde dağılmadan
söz ediyor hem çevresel bunlardan da
çevresel faydalar var bu eşsiz biçimde
da almanın farklısın bir grup ve
cinsiyete sahip insanlar arasında
olduğundan bahsediyor bu olsa olsa
adalet diye bir kavram olur galiba bu
çevresine davet
çevresel Adalet gerçekten çok da önemli
bir kavram çevresel kavramları arasında
birçok boyutta inceltilebilir dağıtımsal
katılımla ilgili tanıma ve kapasite ile
ilgili farklı farklı boyutları var aynı
zamanda adaletten bahsettiğimiz için
birçok farklı çok ve grupta mekanda
adaletten bahsedebiliriz Örneğin ülkeler
arası ülke içi General arası ve farklı
türler Örneğin hayvanlar ve bitkiler ya
da bitkiler ve insanlar arası adaletten
özelliği olabiliriz Gerçekten harika bir
dünya olurdu çevresine davetin gerçekten
var olduğu bir dünya böyle bir dünya var
olması için önerimiz nedir Finans'ın ve
ekonominin yeniden düzenlenmesi yeni bir
ekonomik Sistem nedir finansal Belki de
Finansal sistemin olma bu suların
silindiği yeniden dağıtım
mekanizmalarının devreye soğukluğu bir
dünya Aynı zamanda da yeşil dönüşüm için
teknoloji transferinin gerçekleştiği
telif haklarının olmadığı yenilenebilir
teknolojiler için veya ücretsiz olduğu
bir dünyada söz etmek isteriz umarım en
kısa zamanda insanlar çevresine ne kadar
önemli olduğunun farkına varır uyanır ve
de böyle bir düzene böyle bir yeni dünya
düzeninde ulaşmak için adım atmaya
başlarız
arasındaki çatışma ve gelinlerin
çevresel faktörlerden yararlanarak
istediğini düştüğümüz sürecektir Sen
aslında tamamiyle bir süreç ve bu süreç
karışık koruma üretim tesisi ve barışın
inşası olmak üzere üç düzlemde yer
alıyor Bunlardan ilki barışı Kurumu
doğal kaynak bu oyunda çevre
sorunlarından Doğan büyük aylık
uyuşmazlıkların o tavsiyeler bir
çatışmaya düşmeden önce önlenmesini ve
eğer önlenemiyor yada minimal düzeyde
tutulmasını ifade ediyor başım TS çevre
ve doğal kaynak odaklı çalışmaların
oluşturulacak işbirliği mekanizmaları ve
karşılıklı ballı kesildi öğrenmesini ve
barışın inşası ise çalışma sonuç
toplumların temsilcisi kurumların
yeniden yapılandırılması ve doğal
kaynakların ortak yönetimi kapsıyor
bizim burada gelecek için projeksiyonu
ve Aslında önerimiz deliklerin çevresel
süreçleri ve çevresel sorunlara daha
duyarlı yaklaşımları ve çatışmaların
çözümünde ilk tetikleyici olarak bunları
temel almaları ve bu yönde çatışmaları
veya built etmelidir
bir
17. kelimemiz soldan sağa 11 harfli
çevre ilgili herhangi bir faktörün
kalıcı veya geçici kısa veya uzun makro
ve mikro cd18 sonucu insanların yaşam
yerlerini zorunlu olarak terk etmesiyle
meydana gelen göç süreci
bakıyorum alıyorum harflerde uygun
görünüyor
çevresel göç
bulmaca mızdaki ilk kelimenin karşılığı
gibi çevresel göç ve küresel Gündem
maddelerinden bir tanesi geçmişten beri
devam eden Günümüzde ise artık en üst
noktasına ulaşmış
bir süreç ve çevresel etkenlerle güçlü
insanların sayısı oldukça fazla her ne
kadar savaş ve şiddet Temelli nedeniyle
kötü insanlardan insana daha öpmem de
olsa da çevresel faktörlerde 3 edenler
hem istedikleri olarak hem yoğunluk
olarak hem de dünyaya geldi
oldukça fazla bu konuda çözüm önerisi
olarak sorabileceği bir şey Öncelikle
Evet evet çevresel nedenlerin Bir göç
gerekçesi olabildiğini kabul etmek bu
alanda
test et kendine göç eden insanların
tespitini sağlamak
için de Devletlerin ve politik
öğretmesini nevi terimi olan
yoğunlaşmasını sağlamak görüyorum bu
devletler arasında bir gündem maddesi
olmadıkça çevresel gösterişli Bir
Çocuğun neresi çok zordu
bizi Merhaba ben Belkız birden bugün
bulmaca üzerinde sizlere açıklamaya
çalışacağım kavram 8 numarada yer alıyor
ve yukarıdan aşağıya yarılıyor ve ona
harften oluşuyor program nedir bu kavram
insan ve doğa arasındaki
ahlaki ilişkiyi insan ve doğa arasındaki
ilişkiyi ahlaki açıdan inceleyen
disiplinlerarası bir alandır Şimdi
burada en temel Odak noktası ahlaki
değer ne oluyor ve ahlaki değerler
dediğinizde karşınıza eşit disiplini
çıkıyor iki genel anlamda iyi ve kötüye
doğru yanlışa dair sorgulamaları yapan
akademik bir alt alandır diyebiliriz
şimdi buraya kadar sözünü ettiğim
şekilde bir tarafta çevre bir tarafta
ettik Ve ikisi arasındaki ahlak
ilişkiler bu ne olabilir diye baktığımız
zaman olsa çevre için olabilir işte
çevirici çeviri sorunlarını temelinde
yatan nedenlerle açıklamaya çalışan bir
disiplin olarak karşımıza çıkıyor ve
1970'li yıllar biraz da çevresel
sorunların ve artış gösterdiği bir dönem
olarak çevre için gelişim göstermeye
başladığı bir süreçtir diyebiliriz
buradaki temel tartışmalar ise daha çok
ahlaki açıdan kimin ve neyin önemli
olduğunu üzerine yürütülüyor ve en genel
olarak da İnsanı merkeze alan canlıyı
Merkezi alan ve çevreyi Merkezi alan
ettik yaklaşımları burada görüyoruz bu
olarak yaşadığımız bu çevre sorunlarında
bir öneri olarak sunabileceğiniz bir şey
bu noktada
hepimizin doğanın ürer
Hakimiyet değil ya da doğanın efendisi
değil doğanın parçası olduğumuz
gerçeğinden yola çıkarsak Tıpkı diğer
canlılar gibi iş yaşadığımız bu çevresel
sorunların üstesinden bu şekilde
edebiliriz diyorum teşekkür ederim